yeah trying to get back in shape where's
my oh yeah well I mean yeah buddy see I
got my ball going I got other balls
going to boost your testosterone fuel
i'm ryan right i'm salamander sadly
today we're gonna watch several movie
clips of this movie that some people are
talking about it's called Godzilla
really yeah absolutely we did we just
got attacked by Godzilla yesterday but I
didn't wanna made a movie about us hey
the old things about us apparently a
link in the description or like after
there's a video yeah first clip first
clip this one is called Muto mutant
mutant but not know we don't know what
it is does massive unidentified
terrestrial organism is however no
longer terrestrial it is therefore more
ah
you think by this was an earthquake yeah
it would be preferable that that remain
so before we lost sight of it it was
headed east across the Pacific and had
emitted enough EMP disruption to create
havoc with our radar and satellite feeds
and reduce us for the moment to a
strictly visual pursuit I'm so excited
for this this guy's good actor man
because we will get on argue that guy
and we will find this victim it is
imperative that we do sleep alright good
warm-up button yeah good warm-up clip
yeah crap going on we got these you know
new monsters and one of them ticket of
the flies but that's just the first clip
oh wow God you know that clue made me
want to watch more clips definitely oh
my god we go kind of look like if
battleship were a good movie yeah looks
like a good sci-fi movie I like the
script so far this one's called you need
to get out of there
this might be emotional might be it
bryan cranston line
oh god see we have full function
we are of pubs we should be jointly done
to so intense
take us offline Joe we got a tower now
wind it down
get to know me pace over though what are
you saying
Ott's the lowers wife dies
run [ __ ] cedra listen to me Oh
I'm getting down to myself put the
safety doors on manual override I cannot
do that keep the doors open my he makes
you really give a [ __ ] oh that's gonna
be a sad moment at all my heart stirring
something completely timed you thank you
I love it man they got the intensity
there man they got the emotion there
it's rare when you get that from a
summer blockbuster sides was in there
his mess not gonna cook [ __ ] I don't
want to cook look [ __ ] you're good go
order cook cook [ __ ] all right what's
his clip call what's his clip call
I deserve answers you're lying mm-hmm I
want myself I will see my son I want to
know that he's all right
this guy this guy knows he knows where
he is it's great I know you know him I
want my son and I want my bag and this
one top seller in charge
thank you no I'm not talking to you oh
my god
all right well you're looking at me
right now giving a fish 10 right that's
funny because I know what happened here
you keep telling everybody that this
place is a Death Zone but it's not
you're lying because what's really
happening is that you're hiding
something out there I'm right honey
my wife died here something killed my
wife
and I ever write to know what is your
answers I'm tearing up right now and
that's just a movie clip yeah like damn
I'm crying right now oh my god
do my eyes that's never happened to me
watching a clip oh my god
he's my I don't what a great [ __ ]
actor man like you know when when
they're nominated for an Oscar they show
that we have it's just like so intense
what's sad is he looks like he's gonna
do a great [ __ ] amazing job but he's
probably not even gonna get Oscar
consideration cuz yeah it's Godzilla but
[ __ ] man he looks like he's given 1l of
a performance he will get an Oscar win
am patient yeah he'd better any or
anyone like I mean this is the movie
that's gonna make him a movie star
this one's called this is my job you
just picture Godzilla being like this is
my job I'm supposed to destroy things I
just walked in things fall out the
high-risk mission that train out there
is a national asset not Amtrak we good
to go just about when the look of the
casings on those Minuteman ICBMs I'm
guessing a digital modules been bypassed
and you're prepping for full analog
retrofit my jobs a problem me again
know what you mean I do the words I
don't know yeah I know what they're
doing aim the pointy end at the monsters
right Sarge
what was the last time you let one of
you get
in a live bomb look this is what I do
this is my job you said it master
sergeant
my family's in the city okay I need to
get on that train god damned yeah I love
these clips because they're all like
acting yeah it's it's like saying hey
we're more than just a monster film like
this is just this is real like heavy
character stuff I mean they didn't even
honestly have to do that you know I
accepted I expected kind of like
transformers really have good acting
half not and just a big action film but
this is like no they're honoring this
story is gonna be the foam of the year
like I'm putting that out there right
now I'm gonna buy a poster just because
how awesome me some trailers are I'm
gonna buy Bryan Cranston toy let them
fight this one might have Godzilla
feature - anytime the pterodactyl thing
oh dude I be cool let's see this
this alpha predator of yours doctor do
you really think he has a chance
your arrogance of man is thinking nature
is in our control he took my life why
you said your line
that's who plays you that don't fight
I'm fine
Oh rego please please please oh damn oh
it's gonna be awesome it on that
oh the king
oh I can't wait to see that bite ah
that's gonna be awesome
oh he's a cute cute he's adorable was
Godzilla or neither
lizards are so cute he's just a big one
he's just like a big dirty bird is there
this is ooh yeah this is the reaction
Studios want from Godzilla sorry
we want people to think he's clear it
wasn't be running an STI can I get a hug
anyway guys thanks for recommending
those clips to us that was that was
awesome I was really worth it so excited
yeah that was really good if you're new
to the channel subscribe subscribe to
Sally's to did I spit on you my stink
okay this way in another face yeah then
you can appreciate Sally watch our video
that was you know Godzilla this movie
was inspired by our video so watch it
called Godzilla alert inspired by the
Godzilla other videos where guys will
attack attack one of the two forgot it's
that time of the video where people get
mad because I didn't hear their name
it's the shout out time let's see who's
next on the list
and we go in order we don't play faves
ease here Aaron Bailey he wanted me to
mention someone Elena Alana Alana joy
wanna join Joey it's probably wanna and
she is beautiful I know this through
comments specifically his common uh
Aaron Bailey Oersted oh man dude doing
that what a prince oh dude yeah I hope
you're not related to her I hope that's
a girlfriend or something
she ain't sampling well let me reply
back not him he's not letting me reply
bet got a fixture account so I can reply
back to your comments cuz he leaves
several comments but I feel like a dick
when I don't reply back am i boring you
salamander oh I I didn't drink my tea oh
okay good when I look into your eyes my
heart stops and then your heart just
stopped and you were again yeah so fix
your account man yeah another one of
those is Jones Lavery yeah Jones Oh
Avery same problem with your account
yeah fix your [ __ ] account geez man
we can love you that's the only reason
why that's why it's you know it might
communicate his anger but it's luck race
line Matt he's been asking for weeks
where's my shoutout where's my shoutout
think you've got a shoutout
you're finally Huck yeah listen to the
while I don't know if that was a black
girl actually that was racist of me to
assume I already got in trouble for
making a racist joke it wasn't supposed
to be racist but people got offended so
wasn't supposed to be right it wasn't oh
I can see - what's up ha ha ha
Matt one of the people who wrote in the
Bible Matthew Matthew yes good job
good job on that race into the top
you're named after a good person man
good person good Matthew des Christophe
he wanted a high she saw the 4/20 video
and he wanted a high shadow Sally
doesn't touch the wheat um but I can be
like that's a high shoutout yes
crosstalk I don't want to pretend to be
stoned I want you know if I'm gonna be
stoned shout out it's gonna be a raw
authentic marijuana session you know
what I'm coming right back stay right
there so are you a sailor yeah actually
yeah I D is Christophe that's not fast I
get high one hit and it does it I'm
really horny now I locked the door Sally
okay you can't get out you need a key to
get out something's gonna go down
tonight we're going to a concert that's
what's going down okay that's that's it
yeah concert in my pants oh I hope my
boyfriend isn't watches are you talking
about
he loves me kind of let me loosen this
up more bay oh sub Nick